Musik Du musst wissen, wir sind ein bisschen wie Bären. Wir haben mehr Angst vor dir als du vor uns, wirklich wahrscheinlich. Wir sind aufgeregter.
Kannst du bitte dein Mikrofon in die Hand nehmen? Wir müssen das alles noch, das Gespräch komplett von vorne anfangen. Wir machen erstmal Sprachübungen. Stefan?
Ich schlag was vor.
Mach dir das ernsthaft immer. Na, na, na, na, na, na, ra, ra, ra, bra, bra. Sind das Katzen, die nur in der Wohnung bleiben können oder müssen die auch raus? Nehmen wir schon auf? Nee. Oder müssen die auch raus? Ist das jetzt geheime Information oder was, was du bei den Katzen sagen kannst? Ja, ich fühl mich schlecht, dass die Katzen nicht raus dürfen. Also wo sollen die denn hier hin? Ich bin ja mitten in der Stadt. Also die gehen auf dem Balkon. Aber es gibt ja so Stadtkatzen, die man nicht auslassen muss, weil die ja auch nicht wollen. Ja, das sind eigentlich so typische Wohnungskatzen. Also ich habe die Rasse auch ausgewählt, weil die angeblich gute Wohnungskatzen sind. Ja, das können ja auch so Budi-Ellenkatzen sein, die es vielleicht gar nicht mögen, so nach in die draussen, in die Außenwelt gehen und kommunizieren, die es vielleicht ganz gerne haben. Das Einzige, was ich über Katzen weiss, ist, dass sie sehr rein sind. Und das lenkt die andere gerade in dem anderen dieses Arschloch aus. Entschuldigung, aber das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich, ich habe allen Sachen bei sich über Katzen und dies wurde gerade einfach widerlegt. Aber wie eine Katze guckt, können wir nicht mal von diesen Tieren irgendein Geräusch bekommen, irgendwas? Emil, ich warte, ich hole mal deren Lieblingsspielzeug, aber dann drehen die völlig durch. Okay, mach mal. Da werden die wahrscheinlich was sagen. Oder irgendein Geräusch bekommen. Irgendwas. Emil! Ich warte, ich hole mal deren Lieblingsspielzeug, aber dann drehen die völlig durch.
Da werden die wahrscheinlich was sagen. Wir brauchen da irgendein Geräusch einfach.
Derzeit können wir uns vorstellen, was wir hier machen und wo wir hier sind.
Wir, Florentin und Stefan,
Ah, du singen es!
Ja, ist okay.
Sind jetzt endlich mal, was wir in Folge 9 bereits angekündigt haben,
wird endlich Wahrheit.
Wir sind bei einer Hörerin zu Hause, also Hörerin war uns auch sehr wichtig. Die Grossangelegte, das Podcast UFO Home Story. Und nicht nur sind wir bei einer Hörerin zu Gast, sondern auch bei ihren beiden Katzen, die gerade fantastische Kutsche vollführen. Emil und Elfi. Wir müssen das so ein bisschen radioreportage-mäßig beschreiben. Vier Pfoten, eine Schnauze und unendlich viele Haare. Das sind ungefähr die körperlichen Merkmale von Emil, der Katze von Cordula, bei der wir heute zu Hause sind. Und die gerade so unfassbar dumm ist, dass sie denkt, als wären drei Federn an der Schnur tatsächlich ein echter Vogel. Ist nicht der Fall. Oh, ist das geplant oder hat sie es gerade kaputt gemacht? Aber sie geben immer noch keinen Ton von sich. Was machen sie denn jetzt. Das sind die schlechtesten Podcast-Katzen. Kannst du nicht mal kurz ein Wort sagen, irgendwas? Eben, sag mal was. Herzlich willkommen beim... Ja, und jetzt die grossen Stars sitzen jetzt hier in deinem Wohnzimmer. Also rückblickend, vor einem Jahr. Hättest du was gedacht, dass das mal passiert, dass deine grossen Stars in deinem Wohnzimmer, also die grossen Stars? Okay, ihr wollt jetzt, dass ich so ein bisschen Arsch krieche, also ich bin total froh, dass ihr hier seid, wirklich, also ich habe überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet, dass ihr das tatsächlich machen würdet. Aber geh noch mal ganz kurz auf dieses Froh ein, also versuch mal deine Gefühle zu beschreiben, also was geht innerlich vor in dir, wenn du uns, Weil ihr seht ja schon Stars in deinem Wohnzimmer. Ja, für mich seid ihr Stars. Und zwar, weil ... Also das Komische ist, ich kenne euch ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Ich höre aber seit Ewigkeiten, also seit Ewigkeiten, so lange gibt es den Podcast ja noch nicht, aber ich höre schon sehr lange diesen Podcast. Warum hörst du genau diesen Podcast? Du hättest ja auch zum Beispiel einen Einschlafenden Podcast. Oder du hättest ja Radio Nikola hören können. Oder Gäste Liste Geisterbahn. Du hörst ja nur unseren Podcast. Ja, ich hatte sanft und sorgfältig schon durch und dann musste ich was anderes hören. Ne, ähm, das hören wir gar nicht gern. Okay, meine Kleine Schwester hat mir den empfohlen. Also ich habe sanft und sorgfältig schon immer ... Moment, und deine Kleine Schwester hört ja immer mit ihrem Freund zusammen, hört die immer den Podcast? Genau. Kann die Hände mal. Das ist so deren intime stunde nee also ich höre immer habe beim joggen ist aber nur eine folge pro woche und dann kam mir das wie gelegen als meine kleine schwester sagte da gibt es einen anderen coolen podcast von joggst mehr als einmal die Ja. Wie oft joggst du die Woche? So dreimal ungefähr. Alter, Alter. Deshalb müssen wir eigentlich zwei Folgen mindestens pro Woche machen, damit das hinhaut. Ach du Scheiße. Ja, dann hau mal rein, Florianthin. Das ist echt krass. Ich glaube, wir haben echt den perfekten Menschen hier gefunden. Also wirklich, du hast einen guten Job, du hast eine supergeile Wohnung, du hast Katzen, du bist sportlich, du bist gesund. Perfekt. Du hast alles richtig gemacht. Du hast Booster gekauft, alle Sorten Booster gekauft. Ich habe alles, ja, ich besitze alle Sorten Booster. Ich komme mir so langweilig vor dagegen. Ja, oh Gott, was soll ich jetzt sagen, außer dass das nicht stimmt. Aber ganz kurz, du joggst wirklich dreimal die Woche. Also wenn ich joggen würde, könnte ich dabei keinen Podcast hören, glaube ich. Aber es ist sterbenslangweilig, weil ich dabei nichts höre. Aber ich kann nicht mal hören dabei, weil ich so sehr mit Joggen ... Joggen ist für mich eine primäre Tätigkeit. Das ist ein Überlebenskampf. Ich kann damit nichts anderes machen. Du siehst schon die Geier, die anfangen, über dir zu kreisen. Ich nehme um mich herum nichts wahr, ich sehe Sternchen nach zehn Metern, und dann muss ich mich erstmal hinsetzen. Dank der Krankenwagen erstmal die nächsten drei Stunden. Aber ganz genau so ging mir das am Anfang auch und ich höre ja jetzt mein Atmen auch nur nicht, weil ich was höre. Ich soll euch auch noch sagen, warum ich auch einen Podcast so gerne höre. Es gibt ja noch ganz viele andere Podcasts, die ich hören kann und ich habe tatsächlich auch mehrere ausprobiert, aber ich, ähm, ich weiß nicht, ich, ach Gott, hätte ich mir mal vorher überlegen sollen, was spontane Reaktion. Das ist halt tatsächlich so, als würde ich einfach einmal die Woche zwei Leuten so beim Quatschen zuhören.
Es ist so ein bisschen so, als würdet ihr euch, also fühlt sich so an, zwei Freunde treffen sich, unterhalten sich, treffen ziemlich gut so meinen Humor.
Es wirkt recht planlos, was ich gut finde.
Also nicht jede Folge ist voll der Hit und ich lache mich kaputt, aber es ist immer interessant und überraschend. Aber du hast hier letztlich doch schon mehr erwartet von uns, oder? Nein. Nee, wirklich? Weil ich glaube, wir sind im Podcast auch lustiger und unterhaltsamer als so. Das kam mir gerade vor allem der Weg von deiner Haustür hierhin quasi jetzt gerade und dieses awkward aufbauen unserer Technik, das fand ich so unangenehm. Und ich mir dachte, da hören Leute wirklich dann uns und finden uns vielleicht cool, weil wir da auch performen dann im Podcast. Ja. Und das können die ja auch gut finden, das verstehe ich. Und dann laden die uns dann ein netterweise, sehen uns dann aber, wie wir dann so awkward irgendwie im Wohnzimmer nach Steckdosen suchen. Das ist so unangenehm für mich.
Genau, wo man nicht dahinter denkt.
So dieses ganze, wie wird das Überraschungsei gemacht sozusagen.
Das will man ja nicht sehen.
Man will ja nur das perfekte, auf vinyl gepresste Gold haben.
Aber du willst nicht wissen, wie es entsteht.
Du willst auch beim McDonald's, gut, du wirst es wahrscheinlich nie zum McDonald's gehen,
sondern bei Alnatura, Flatrate, hier jeden Tag, ich kriege meine Kiste Gemüse hier.
Und dann mache ich mir selber ein leckeres Risotto. Überhaupt nicht. Ich erinnere mich hauptsächlich von Schokolade. Zusammen, aber auch nur von Lind. Ja, weil Lind hier in Aachen direkt ist, deshalb. Boah, du hast echt informiert, ja klar, natürlich. Aber tatsächlich mag ich lieber andere Schokolade als die von Lind. Zum Beispiel? Soll ich Werbung machen? Ja. Ich mag, glaube ich, am liebsten Rport. Wenn du für diese Firmen hier Werbung machst, ist das in Ordnung. Ich glaube Rittersport. Lint ist mir zu... Rittersport wird die schlechteste Schokolade der Welt. Echt? Das ist so furchtbar. Aber für Rittersport interessiert dich sehr, ne? Da hast du ja... Ja, ich habe mal bei dem Gewinnspiel mitgemacht. Das weiss ich so. Und hast du da gewonnen? Ich habe schon bei ganz vielen Rittersport Gewinnspielen mitgemacht. Ich habe auch mal gewonnen, ja. Was hast du gewonnen? Ich habe leider nicht, eigentlich wollte ich immer die Ritterrente gewinnen, die gab es mal zu gewinnen vor ein paar Jahren. Die Ritterrente? Kriegst du deine eigene Burg oder wie? Ne, ne, ne, du bekommst bis ans Ende deines Lebens jeden Tag eine Tafel Schokolade von dir. Jeden Tag? Aber du darfst davon aussuchen, welche? Wie bitte? Davon aussuchen, welche? Ja, also die schicken dir, glaube ich, einmal im Monat oder alle paar Wochen irgendwie so eine Kiste, wo dann halt entsprechend viele Tafeln drin sind. Wie gut ist das denn? Und ich bin inzwischen vielleicht doch ein bisschen froh, dass das nicht geklappt hat. Sonst müsstest du fünfmal in der Woche jonglen. Wollte ich eins zu eins auch so machen. Hätte siebenmal gesagt, aber... Also ich esse auch jetzt, glaube ich, eine Tafel-Schokolade am Tag. Was mein Vater mir immer gekauft hat, waren so Rittersport, aber direkt aus der Fabrik, und die waren halt nicht einzeln eingepackt, sondern es war einfach so eine Papiertüte vom Bäcker und einfach ranvoll mit Schokoladentafeln, die aber dann halt immer so Fehler hatten, wo dann halt irgendwie dann, da war dann Marzipan nur zur Hälfte drin oder da war dann zu viel Marzipan. Das war dann nur Verpackung. Ja, und das Marzipan war außen und die Schokolade war innen oder so ganz abgefahrene Sachen, wo sich denkt so, hä, das ist doch eine Maschine, die das herstellt, wie zur Hölle kann das sein? Also mega gut, weil einfach Berge der Schokolade hat. Ich kann mir gar nicht erklären, wie ich trotzdem so schlank geblieben bin, meine ganze Jugendliche. Das Gleiche haben wir hier bei Lind. Also da kauft man dann auch so eine ganze Tüte voll mit Tafeln, die nicht verpackt sind. Ach, das ist geil. Wir haben bei uns Busy Bear, heißt das. Das ist eine Zeitschrift für kleine Kinder, oder? Ja, und die Kratzeisen, die machen Kratzeis. Ah, ja,? Diese Becher, wo sehr viel Eis halt drin ist, dass man kratzt. Booster gefroren quasi. Oder diese langen, länglichen Eis aus dieser Plastikverpackung, die man so wie eine Beefy rausrücken muss. Wo das einzige coole der Rest, also der Saft ist, der am Ende überbleibt. Genau. Und das ist so ungesund, aber alle haben das bei uns immer im Überfluss gehabt, weil das bei uns sehr die Verpflichtung war. Aber das ist doch eine schöne Metapher. Du würdest dir nie, auch wenn du dir selber diese Llichen Eisdinger kaufen würdest, du würdest ja nie die ungefroren einfach trinken. Du musst sie schon gefrieren, dann schmelzen und dann trinken. Also das ist dann das Beste. Und ist das nicht auch eine gute Metapher für den Podcast, dass du nicht wissen willst, wie es entstanden ist, weil du es nur auf eine ganz bestimmte Art genießen kannst. Oder diese ganze Sache mit seines, man darf seine Stars nicht treffen und so, sondern dass es ein ganz spezieller Modus sein muss, wo es Sinn ergibt. Und auch obwohl es vom Physikalischen keinen Unterschied macht, ob es jetzt einmal gefroren wurde und dann wieder schmilzt oder ob es einfach nie gefroren wurde, es ist trotzdem Unterschied, weil es ist einmal so ein Bonus, du hast dein Eis und als Bonus hast du noch die Flüssigkeit und die ist nur gut, weil es ein Bonus ist und wenn du nur Bonus hast,
hundert Prozent Bonus, dann hast du diesen Status nicht mehr, dann ist es nicht mehr gut.
Und so war es auch mit diesen Fehldingern, weil die, nein, das funktioniert jetzt nicht mit meinem
Stapher, geht nicht auf. Und wo gehst du dann laufen? Wie läufst du denn dann? Läufst du dann so
Formen, dass man bei Rantastic irgendwie, läufst du quasi dann bei uns das Herz.
Ja, ich habe so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine,
genau, genau, ich laufe dann immer, also euren Namen so langsam, dass es genau einen Podcast lang ist. Oder so ein riesengroßes Tic-Tac-Toe. Ne, tatsächlich laufe ich ganz langweilig im Kreis rum. Ich glaube, das kommt noch vom Anfang, als ich halt wirklich nach einer Runde völlig am Ende war, habe ich mich dann langsam so hochgesteigert und gedacht, oh, jetzt schaffe ich schon drei Runden und so, also im Park. Ah, okay, so habe ich es auch gemacht, ja, tatsächlich. Und inzwischen ist es halt so ein bisschen lame, weil ich dann einfach irgendwie über eine Stunde lang im Kreis laufe. Das ist, glaube ich, das grösste Problem, was ich habe, warum ich nicht jogge, weil ich Angst habe, nicht zu wissen, wo ich langlaufe und dann im Stehenbleibe, awkward, und sollte mich sehen, wie ich im Sportanzug stehe. Aber auch da ist es immer total interessant, weil du siehst, Jogger nie starten oder enden. Genau. Du siehst Jogger nur immer an dir vorbeilaufen. Deswegen ist es mir so unangenehm, anzufangen zu joggen. Ja genau, aber das ist auch so eine Situation, wie du siehst nie Babytauben oder so. Das ist so, die siehst du nur auf eine ganz spezielle Art. Ich habe mal Babytauben gesehen. Das ist echt, du bist der von der perfekten Mensch der Welt. Hier gegenüber. Warum kannst du alles? Die Babytauben sind die hässlichsten, aller aller hässlichsten Babytiere überhaupt. Aber hier gegenüber, beim Fenster meiner Nachbarn, gab es ein Nest mit Tauben, die da Kinder bekommen haben. Erst mal haben die alles komplett zugekackt, die ganze Fassade war voll. Und die Kinder, ich habe die ganz lange nicht gesehen, weil das Nest war in so einem Blumenpott und ich habe die ganze Zeit gehofft, die endlich sehen zu können. zu können und als ich die dann gesehen habe, war ich so enttäuscht, die waren ungefähr genauso groß wie die Eltern, aber so unfassbar hässlich. Sie hat das geheimnisvollste Spektakel der Natur entdeckt und sie war trotzdem enttäuscht. Ja, ich war so enttäuscht. Du hast massenmessig das Eindruck, du schwebst auf so einer Metaebene über allen Menschen. Du warst wahrscheinlich auch der Kommentator, der gesagt hat, perfekte Podcast, mehr aber auch nicht. Ich habe Babytauben gesehen, mehr aber auch nicht. Ich habe noch nie auf dem Podcast kommentiert. Weiß ich nicht. Das finde ich spannend. Die Suche nach Stefan Schwer geht weiter. Irgendwann finden wir dich. Wir vermuten bei jeder Person, die uns kennt, dass es Stefan Schwer ist im Geheimen. Also wir wissen auch nicht genau, welche Art von Zuhörer, Zuhörerin kommentiert, also was das für Menschengruppen sind. Und wir dachten, dass in diese Richtung Leute, die in diese Richtung arbeiten, auch dann im nächsten Schritt Leute einladen zu sich selber. Ja, ich wundere mich auch sehr, hatte ich vorher ... Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, Kommentatoren sind von ihrer Natur eher schüchtern und distanziert, aber haben dann dadurch so ein Outlet. Ich glaube, so selbstbewusste und sozial fähige Menschen wie Cordula, die brauchen das gar nicht. Ich würde sagen, dass Cordula auch schüchtern ist, aber sie traut sich gerade nicht. Sie ist überhaupt nicht schüchtern. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Nein, aber das ist eine andere, nein, nein, nein, nein, du kannst mir nicht, nein, das ist genauso wie diese scheiss Nerddebatte. Ich bin Nerd, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Es wird jetzt so lange dauern, das ausführen, aber nein, du kannst nicht sagen, dass du schüchtern bist. Doch, doch, dass du schüchtern bist, ist eine Beleidigung für schüchterne Leute, weil schüchterne Leute würden nicht irgendwelche Leute zu nicht nach Hause machen. Genau, aber warum bitte genau wie das?
Das ist schon mal der erste Schritt.
Ich habe gar nicht damit gerechnet, dass ihr das tatsächlich tut.
Das ist doch egal, aber du hast es trotzdem getan.
Und du hast dann, als wir zugesagt haben, nicht zurückgezogen.
Das heißt, du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass du schüchtern bist.
Jeder Mensch ist irgendwo schüchtern, wenn wir fremde Leute trifft, aber du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass du schüchtern bist.
Weil jeder Mensch, der jetzt zu Hause denkt und sagt, okay, ich sitze seit drei Jahren bei mir im Zimmer und traue mich nicht, mit der Bäckersfrau zu reden, ich bin schüchtern, denkt sie, ihr fickt euch doch, dass ihr schüchtern bist.
Du bist nicht schüchtern.
Ich finde es sehr gut, dass die Menschen in euch doch, dass ihr schüchtern bist. Du bist nicht schüchtern. Ich bin schüchtern. Herzlich willkommen beim Pop-Lars-Ufo, wo man fremde Leute in deren Wohnung ranted. Nein, aber ist okay. Ich bin noch ein bisschen heiser, weil wir die ganze Fahrt hierher gesungen haben, Singladies gesungen haben. Buongior, Senora, bella donna andiamo. Buongiorno, Senora, bella donna andiamo.
Warum müssen wir Sprachüber machen?
Sind die Nachbarn eigentlich schreckhaft?
Ha!
Nicht, also um die Uhrzeit ist das okay, glaube ich.
So dasselbe, wir können jetzt schreien.
Hey, Maraf!
Macht ihr das manchmal, so zum Abreagieren?
Ja.
Lautrum schreien. Ah! Ah! Das wirkt ein bisschen wie Tourette. Arschloch! Ist das eine Rasierklinge? Podcast UFO! Das zweite Bild von oben. Das ist ein Album von Joy Division. Ich weiss gar nicht, so ein bisschen sieht das aus wie so ein Wehenschreiber.
Das trägt jeder Hipster in Berlin als T-Shirt, jeder.
Ich hatte das aber vorher.
Ja, lass uns mal ein bisschen auf deinen Raum eingehen, finde ich sehr gut.
Also man sieht schon mal sehr künstlerisch, popkulturell interessiert, hier Stanley, Kyrig ist dabei, Klimt, wunderbar, wir sehen Monet.
Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht erkannt, das ist Klimt, Gustav Klimt, heißt er so?
Gustav.
Gustav? Gustav. Ich habe nur gelesen, das sind diese Namen, die man nur gelesen kennt. Ja, erzähl uns mal ein bisschen von dir. Was ist, was, was, was ist... Ich bin immer noch ein bisschen sprachlos, Entschuldigung. Ich finde das lustig, dass ihr erzählt, ihr wart nervös und so und hattet Angst, dass ich enttäuscht bin oder ihr performen müsst. Ja gut, du läst uns ein nach Aachen, wir fahren 30 Stunden hierher aus Ungarn, wo normalerweise unser, das Podcast ist, wo haupt. Wo es produziert wird, ja, wo hundert unterbezahlte Kinder den Podcast jeden Tag. Genau, ihr seid das eigentlich gar nicht. Nein, wir sind das nicht, wir bezahlen eine ungarische Publikation. Mittlerweile ist das auch nur noch ein Algorithmus, also der irgendwie alte Geschichten nochmal neu verwendet. Ja, das habe ich gemerkt. Wir dachten, du kaufst uns hier irgendwie Grosssachen und Schokolade und irgendwie so Bekommensgeschenke. Ich habe überlegt, ob ich irgendwie sowas Creepiges mache, wenn ihr reinkommt, erst mal die Tür hinter euch abschliessen oder so. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht, das ist ganz geil. Aber dann hatte ich Angst, dass ihr das irgendwie dann falsch aufnehmt oder so. Aber ich glaube, meine Mutter hat gesagt, ich bin froh, dass ihr zu zweit seid. Und bis zu diesem Satz habe ich das für eine ganz normale Situation gehalten, bis mir aufgefallen ist, dass wahrscheinlich mit mir was nicht stimmt. Weil ich sowas als gar nicht ... Weil du von auftrag zu Fremden nach Hause gegangen bist. Ja, ich würde einfach zu Fremden nach Hause gehen, wenn mir nicht jemand, wenn mir die gesellschaftlich sagen würde, das sollte man vielleicht nicht tun, weil du könntest vergewaltigt werden. Ja, das ist aber tatsächlich dieses Thema creepy, dass Leute immer wieder so sagen, creepy, wo ich mir oft denke, okay, Dinge, die ihr creepy findet, finde ich überhaupt nicht creepy, das heisst, ich bin creepy eigentlich, der ganz logische Rennfolge, die Scherenfolge, wo wir einfach da saßen, haben das erzählt, fanden uns auch nicht geil, aber wir haben uns einfach als Geschichte abgetan. Das fand ich aber auch nicht schlimm. Also ich fand die Geschichte an sich, ist das schlimm, aber ihr habt euch ja nicht darüber lustig gemacht oder gesagt, oder das irgendwie verharmlost. Aber ich glaube auch, dass ich vielleicht ein sehr, also mein Humor da wenig Grenzen kennt. Vielleicht, weil ich viel mit, hauptsächlich mit Männern studiert habe. Aber man merkt dir nicht an, dass du viel mit Männern studiert hast. Weil du weisst, dass du dass du so ... Ich finde Frauen, die mit Männern ... viel mit Männern zu studieren haben, haben dann so eine Ellenbogen-Mechanik, eignen die sich an. Man muss diese Geste dabei sehen, damit man weiß, was es war. Ich würde das merken, wenn jetzt hier eine Frau wäre. Ich glaube, ich wäre auch noch nervöser ... Ich wäre dann richtig schüchtern, wenn ihr Frauen wärt. Ich habe tatsächlich, glaube ich, verlernt ... Wie man mit Frauen umgeht. Ja, ich bin dabei nervöser ... Ja, wir kommen im Club. Ja, scheiße, ne? Ich bin ganz fasziniert, ein Katze spielt gerade den Golfkrieg nach. Nein, und zwar ... Ich hab die Mechanik genau beobachtet. Beide Katzen stürmen zum Fenster, weil ein massiver Vogelschwarm in eine grosse Tanne stürzt. Sie können die Kette gar nicht glauben. Sie können es nicht fassen, dass sie auch nicht da rankommen,, weil ein grosser Vogelschorn direkt von ihrem Fenster fliegt. Sie werden sofort hinterhergesprungen, wenn das Fenster offen wird. Und hat sich deswegen auf ihr Vogelpendant in der Wohnung gestürzt. Das ist quasi das Frustspiel. Mir gefällt es, wenn ich Tiere verstehe, also wenn ich weiss genau, was dieses Tier gerade antreibt. Bei meinem Fisch keine Chance. Ich weiss nicht, was er will, er redet nicht mit mir. Diese toten Augen geben dir gar nichts. Ich verstehe nicht, wenn er an diese beschlagene Scheibe, die mit Algen besetzt ist, immer Hilfe schreibt, verstehe ich nicht genau, was mein er damit jetzt. Aber was genau macht man mit einem Fisch? Also der sieht schön aus wahrscheinlich. Ich fand den Gag ganz gut. Hast du intern gelacht für dich? Hast du in deinem Kopf gelacht? Oder hast du, fandst du es einfach nicht gut jetzt? Nee, das war pures Interesse, ich wollte mich gar nicht darüber lustig machen. Ich habe eben einen Gag gemacht, ich will es als Gag bezeichnen. Der erste Gag der Folge übrigens. Ach so, nur ein... Du hast ja eben gesagt, du lachst nicht laut. Hast du gerade in deinem Kopf gelacht oder fandst du es einfach nicht gut? Ich fand die Vorstellung lustig, dass dein Fisch... äh ja doch. Okay, gut, alles klar. Ich habe mir das bildlich vorgestellt und fand das... Statistisch ist das ganz wichtig für mich, dass ich einen Feedback-Kanal bekomme. Ich habe wirklich selten, dass ich laut lache. Ich habe aber auch tatsächlich noch mal zum Thema Creepy, ich habe mir lange Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie wir dich begrüssen sollen. Also ob Handschlag oder Umarmung, ich war mir nicht sicher und ich dachte mir dann, hm, noch mal unabhängig. Was haben wir denn jetzt gemacht? Ich habe Handschlag. Ich möchte es kurz erklären. Ich dachte mir, eigentlich wäre Umarmung schon angebracht, wir haben schon geschrieben und so und eigentlich schon ein relativ gutes Verhältnis. Wir verstehen uns schon sehr gut. Allerdings dachte ich mir, es ist ein bisschen komisch, wenn ich eine Jacke an habe und du nicht. Und das war letztendlich der ausschlaggebende Punkt für mich, nochmal spontan mich umzuentscheiden und dir die Hand zu geben, weil ich dachte, es ist komisch, wenn du keine Jacke anhast und dann so ein Michelin-Menschen umarmt. Dann würde ich um dich nicht rumkommen mit meinen Armen.
Aber war das die richtige Entscheidung oder hätte ich dich doch umarmen sollen?
Ich hätte nichts dagegen gehabt.
Okay. Scheiße. Aber ich habe tatsächlich auch drüber nachgedacht und ursprünglich dachte ich ja, ich hole euch einen Bahnhof ab.
Und dann dachte ich auch, wahrscheinlich Umarmung vielleicht, wenn dann zum Abschied.
Ah. Achso, dass man dann...
Okay, genau.
Können wir jetzt leicht festlegen, dass wir uns zum Abschied umarmen? Ja. Mal gucken, wohin ... Mal gucken, wie's läuft. Mindestens zehn Sekunden lang würde ich jetzt vorschlagen. Also von mir aus wären zehn Sekunden nur K. Ja, wir können ja laut mitzählen. Und dann ein bisschen genervt sein, weil die zehn Sekunden noch nicht um sind. Ja, ich habe heute so ein Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt an. Und ich habe es noch nicht gewaschen. Die habt ihr beide. Es stinkt ein bisschen, weil es riecht so sehr nach Plastik. Es ist sehr, ich glaube, es ist nicht so gute Qualität. Ach so, es stinkt nicht nach Schweiss, sondern nach, ah ja, verstehe. Ich habe ungelogen. Ich habe gestern, weil ich... Das kratzt auch ein bisschen auf der Haut. Diese Woche wohnte ich gerade in Köln im Hotel, fünf Tage lang, und ich habe mir ohne Witz gestern beim Lidl Spülmittel gekauft, also dieses Waschmaschinen-Spülmittel, und habe noch meine Jacke und Hose im Waschbecken gewaschen gestern haben. Extra für mich. Extra für dich, weil ich mir dachte, ich kann nicht mit fünf Tagen alter Hose hier aufräumen. Das ist auch so ein Ding, wo jetzt viele Leute sagen, du hast doch einen kompletten Schaden oder creepy, aber das hat mich irgendwie so beschäftigt, weil ich mir dachte, ich kann jetzt, weil ich denke mir, weil du weißt ja nicht, dass ich fünf Tage davor im Hotel wohne. Das heißt, du hast ja den Eindruck, den du von mir hast, denkst du, ich bin so immer notwendigerweise, weil du denkst ja nicht, dass es irgendwas Besonderes ist. Deswegen dachte ich mir, wenn sie denkt, ich würde immer komplett mit Senf übersäten Jacke durch die Gegend laufen, hat sie einen schlechten Eindruck von mir. Ach, ich hätte das ein bisschen sympathisch gefunden, glaube ich. Ja, wirklich? Scheiße, verdammt nochmal. So ist auch gut. Ich habe alles falsch gemacht bisher. Also ich finde gut, dass ihr für euch selbst Werbung lauft. Ja, genau, das haben wir uns auch gefragt. Wie cool ist es eigentlich, wenn man selber Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt trägt, also so als Merch. Aber auch wieder so ein Ding, wir können nicht einfach Spaß an unseren eigenen Sachen haben, sondern wir müssen uns wieder mega überdenken und überlegen, ob das cool ist oder nicht. Klappt halt nicht, ne, deine Wasserpistole. Ja, Moment. Ich finde es geil, dass mich, das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass mir ein Gastgeber mir eine Wasserpistole in der eigenen Wohnung gibt. Das ist so ein ganz neues Szenario, was für mich eine ganz neue Welt eröffnet, wo ich mir denke, oh mein Gott, wie gut das ist, dass man einfach die Erlaubnis bekommt von Anfang an, dass die Fronten klar sind, du darfst theoretisch mit einer Wasserpistole in meinem Wohnzimmer rumschiessen. Ich würde so gerne meine Wasserpistole ins Kino mitnehmen, wenn irgendwelche Vollidioten drei Reihen vor mir reden. Kannst du noch, kennt ihr Kennt ihr das beim Popcorn, die Dinger, die nicht gepoppt sind? Ja, ja, ja. Die spuck ich auch immer auf die Leute vor mir. Die spuckst du auch immer auf die Leute vor mir. Ja, wirklich? Was soll ich denn sonst da hin? Also ich meine, ja, manchmal tue ich die nur so unauffällig auf dem Boden, aber ... Du spuckst Popcorn-Kenner auf Leute im Kino, die reden. Ey, wenn du jetzt wirklich ja sagst, mache ich dir hier und jetzt einen Heiratsantrag. Das ist das, was ich hier gehört. Wirklich, das ist das, was ich immer machen möchte. Ja, was soll ich dann jetzt noch machen? Ich hab, ja. Aber ich mich nicht traue, wirklich? Du spuckst. Ich hab das schon mal gemacht. Ernsthaft, ich hab das schon mal gemacht. Nee, aber du spuckst aus Schnippen. Ja, Schnippen, spucken kann ich, weil du spuckst, man kann nicht so gut. Aber aus dem Mund, nicht aus der Packung. Ich hab die im Mund gehabt und konnte die nicht kleinbeissen, weil die ja nicht gepoppt sind. Und dann nehm ich die und werf die auf Leute. Und schnipp sie dann auf Du bist nicht die langweistige Person der Welt, du bist die coolste Person der Welt. Das ist echt cool. Ist halt wie so ein Match, ich habe noch nie jemanden getraut. Ich fühle mich wie Tinder und in der Mitte baust du gerade dieses Match-Zeichen auf. Ich denke mir das jedes Mal, weil wir waren im Kino und ich weiß noch, wir haben uns Jobs angeschaut, aber wir haben auch noch eine gute Story, wie wir gestern zusammen eine Matratze angebaut haben, was somit das Unangenehmste war, was ich je gemacht habe. Aber da haben wir drüber geredet, weil auch irgendwelche Vollidioten die ganze Zeit neben uns geredet haben. Und ich habe den halben Film lang gedacht, warum bin ich nicht mutig genug, mit den Leuten einfach zu sagen, können ihr mal bitte kurz eure Fresse halten? Echt, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass du dich das nicht traust. Doch, der ist total sauer und macht da nichts, was dazu führt, dass er den ganzen Film lang die Leute wütend anstarrt und den Film nicht mehr sieht. Also was ist jetzt schlimmer, wenn Leute neben dir reden und du die ganze Zeit die anstarrst oder wenn du einfach mal was sagen würdest wenigstens. Weil das bringt ja so auch gar nichts. Du kannst lieber mit dir hier aufreden. Ich bin dann so erbärmlich, ich denke, ich bin dann so wie die genervte Mutter, die dann so, sie sind genervt, als ob die das interessieren würden. Ich werde euch jetzt ganz kurz nochmal, damit die Spielregeln klar sind, ist es beide links und rechts rum, ich habe eine Wasserpistole in der Hand. Wenn ein Gag von euch nicht zündet, werde ich euch ins Gesicht spritzen, okay? Dann mache ich besser gar keine. Sehr gut. Nein, das ist keine Lösung, also sonst würde ich alle fünf Minuten... Wenn du keinen Gag machst, kriegst du auch einen. Sonst würde ich ungefragt alle fünf Minuten... Ich dachte, das war eure Aufgabe, ihr macht das ja beruflich. Andere Idee, wenn ihr einen Gag macht, spritze ich dem anderen ins Gesicht. Ich dachte, ich wäre da zum Schleimen hier. Sehr gut, hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Hat mich nicht mehr getroffen.
Nicht mehr getroffen.
Sehr gut.
Nein, ich werfe mir einfach ein paar Begriffe in den Raum und du sagst mir, wie du emotional dazu stehst.
Also ich soll da einen Begriff zurückwerfen?
Nee, was hat denn dieser rote Mandel da zu bedeuten, der hier hängt?
Den habe ich mir irgendwann mal gekauft, aber den trage ich fast nie.
Aber der hängt ja so weggeschässig.
Ich vergesse auch Wöcheln, also ich vergesse ständig, dass ich ihn überhaupt besitze, weil ich da halt normalerweise meine Klamotten nicht aufbewahre. Und dann sehe ich ihn öfter und dann fällt mir das ein. Das ist nämlich ein bisschen an Schinders Liste irgendwie so ein bisschen. Ja, hat was. Oh Gott. Aber ich dachte wirklich, es wäre so als Filmhommage gedacht, weil du hier überall so filmst. Ja, ist es auch. Und auch im Flur. Schinders Liste. Und deswegen Schinders Liste. Nee, da hatte ich einfach nur eine Geschmacksverehrunghrung. Ich finde es schön. Kann ich den mal anziehen später? Wie nennt man denn diesen Stil von Klimt? Keine Ahnung. Impressionismus. Ich habe tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich das abhänge. Ich finde das auch zu klischeehaft. Ich finde es auch ein bisschen gruselig. Aber es ist wirklich so, wir waren gestern bei Ziels nach Köln und ich habe ein komplett leeres Zimmer momentan. Und wir waren gestern beim Baumarkt und haben eine Lampe gekauft. Und da gab es dann auch so ganz viele Bilder und Posten, wo man sich einfach denkt, unabhängig davon, ob mir die Motive gefallen, ich kann doch kein Bild beim Baumarkt kaufen, oder? Das geht doch nicht. Aber es gibt Leute, die das machen. Oder bin ich dann wieder so Möchtegern-Hipster-mäßig? Ist es was, was normale Leute machen? Ist es nicht noch uncooler, zu sagen, ich bin zu cool, als mich beim Baumarkt einzukaufen, als einfach beim Baumarkt zu kaufen? Ja, das stimmt. Du schränkst dich ja dann auch ein. Ja, aber man ist so möchte gern super cool, obwohl ich offensichtlich nicht super cool bin. Und ich offensichtlich habe keine Ahnung von Kunst. War das dieses graue Poster von New York mit den zwei gelben Taxis, oder das, wo die Typen alle auf dem Balken sitzen? Oder die Gummibärchen? Nee, das ist mit diesem computeranimierten Strand, wo so vier nackte Frauen drin und so Palmwetter immer über den Russen sind. Da habe ich mir lange überlegt, ob ich mir das kaufen soll. Was ich an dir sehr uncool finde, ich habe mir ja diesen Pulp Fiction Poster in meiner Wohnung. Das Gute ist, dass jetzt keiner weiss, mit wem du redest, wenn du einfach dir sagst. Das stimmt, ja, das ist gut. Der Grund, warum ich nicht so heiß auf Lohonten ist, ich habe einen Pulp Fiction Poster in meiner Wohnung hängen. Und der hat sich darüber lustig gemacht. Weil ich einfach ein Fan des Films bin, den cool finde und weil ich das Poster auch schön finde und du hast mich dafür verurteilt. Du meintest, es wäre so random. Es ist auch so ein Klischee-Poster. Ja, genau. Aber das meine ich, wenn du den Film cool ... Ich habe auch ein T-Shirt von Pulp Fiction. Aber guck mal, nein, wenn ... Schau mal, angenommen, du bist Set-Designer und du bekommst die Aufgabe, designe das Zimmer eines Studenten, dann hängst du da rein, einmal diese Banksy-Fotos, Entschuldigung, nichts gegen dich, diesen Klimt und einen ... Einen Kroster. Ja, und ein Pulpfiction-Poster. Das ist einfach quinnisell. Und ich meine, deine Wohnung sieht halt einfach aus. Du könntest noch Home an die Wand schreiben. Deine Wohnung sieht halt einfach aus wie ein Filmset. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Weißt du, du hast zum Beispiel hat Stefan, der Mensch, der vom Lebenstechnisch so weit vom Konzept Bar entfernt ist, wie man nur sagen kann, hat sowohl eine Minibar als auch das Bild Nighthawks, wo man auch einfach sagt so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so, das ist so,. Er trinkt beide nicht, oder? Ich habe so eine Art, ich trinke nicht gerne in Gesellschaft. Also ich trinke ... Das ist aber traurig, du besäufst dich alleine. Das hat mein Unkel auch immer gesagt. Ja, das ist immer der Moment, wo ich denke, jetzt sollte ich vielleicht doch nicht trinken, wenn ich irgendwie was trinke und dann merke ich, ich trinke alleine. Nee, bei mir ist klassisch Kontrollverlustangst. Kann ich gut verstehen. Und wenn ich alleine bin, kann ich keine Kontrolle verlieren. Kannst du schon, aber keine Bezeugung. Also habe ich schon vor zehn Jahren meine Kontrolle verloren. Ist das so... Ihr müsst ganz kurz erklären, woher was ich gemacht habe. Das ist noch von meinen Eltern aus deren Studentenbude. Ich dachte, ich dachte es aus seinem Gynäkologi-Studium. Das ist ein rückenfreundlicher Stuhl. Mann, ey, jetzt habe ich mal einen einigermassen guten Gag gemacht und zwei Leute reden rein. Ich dachte, der ist noch aus deinem Gynäkologie-Studium. Ist nicht lustig, weil die Hörer ihn nicht sehen. So, aber die Lachen, es hat gut funktioniert, wunderbar, dankeschön. Ich war gerade mit mir eine Anekdote und du gehst einfach. Wir haben noch drei Anekdote auf dem. Aber da sitzt man nicht so drauf, das ist ein Gebetsstuhl, man sitzt mit den Knien drauf. Dieser Teil, die letzten... Ich bin streng gläubig. Ihr könnt jetzt einfach fünf Minuten nach vorne skippen, weil ihr das Zehteil nicht verstehen werdet, weil ihr diesen Stuhl nicht seht. Also er sieht aus wie ein Arzt Schlitten, würde ich sagen. Den kennt man eigentlich auch, das ist so ein Klassiker. Ich glaube, du schaffst es heute den kaputt zu machen, obwohl er älter ist als ich. Ist das die normale Haltung? Also man setzt sich drauf und tut die Knie auf diese beiden Polster und dann ist das ... die Knie? Das geht doch nicht. So oder was? Ja, und dann sitzt man so gerade. Das ist der beste Stuhl der Welt. Wie gut ist das denn? Was ist die unkomfortables Körperhaltung? Und dann soll er noch wirken können und wir bauen noch eine Klingel dran. Das ist eine Mischung aus, man kniet, aber man sitzt auch gleichzeitig. Wie bist du auf dieses Bild gekommen? Also mich interessiert es wirklich, wie konkret du dieses Bild gemacht hast. Redest du immer noch von Clint? Ja. Oh, das ist aber jetzt okay. Ich habe das gleiche Bild als Tee-Dose. Oh Gott, das wird aber jetzt traurig vielleicht ein bisschen. Ich habe das gleiche Bild auf so einer kleinen Tee-Dose, die in der Küche steht, die meine Eltern mal ... Auf einer Urne. ... mir mitgebracht haben von ... Aus Auschwitz? ... ihrer ... aus Auschwitz. Gott, jetzt lache ich. Guck, wenn es so unangenehm wird, dann muss ich lachen.
Dann kann ich erst mal kurz,
merke, Teedose, mir ist nämlich letztens
oder neulich, was auf der Arbeit passiert,
das war wirklich unangenehm. Da habe ich auch in einem Moment gelacht,
wo man einfach nicht lachen sollte.
Und zwar ging es irgendwie um...
Arbeitskollege gestorben. Ja, genau, so in der Art.
Also, es ging um eine Klausuraufsicht,
wo wir halt alle als Assistenten mithelfen müssen.
Und zu irgendwem wurde dann gesagt, da gibt es zwei Studenten, die dürfen länger schreiben, die haben mehr Zeit, die schreiben unter in der Bibliothek und du hältst bitte Aufsicht. Das sind Ausländer. Und dann wurde... Ne, noch schlimmer. Juden? Ausländer haben wir sowieso viele da. Was auch lustig ist, ich neige halt auch schon mal dazu, irgendwie so Witze zu reissen, die, wenn man das nicht versteht, einen glauben lassen könnten, ich wäre irgendwie rassistisch oder so, was auf gar keinen Fall so ist. Und ich ging immer davon aus, guck mal, jetzt versuche ich gerade drei Geschichten... Das musst du auch nicht dazu sagen. Ich versuche gerade drei Geschichten gleichzeitig erzählen, da geht jetzt keiner mehr durch. Wir sind ausgebildete Moderatoren, wir müssen was tun. Und neulich meich meinte meine Mutter dann so, von irgendjemandem erzählt, meinte, das ist ein Inder, aber Inder magst du ja nicht, ne?
Ich so, bitte was?
Also wenn ich vor ihr so einen Witz reiße, kommt dann auch immer so, Gott, so habe ich dich doch nicht erzogen und so.
Oh Gott!
Stell dir vor, du bist in der Klasse oder so und alle wissen es, nur sie war ja selber nicht, aber das ist hier keine Inder-Marke. Und irgendwie in der Klasse stecken wir den Ahmed, Ahmed, wir kennen nicht schon Namen ein. Wir haben jetzt Indisch bestellt, aber für dich natürlich. Okay. So alle seit Jahren wissen es alle ausordnen. Ja, doch kochen kann die für mich ruhig. So Inder-Hast. Aber das ist, glaube ich, der grösste Albtraum, dass man mit seinen Eltern redet und plötzlich merkt, die haben alles ernst genommen, was uns in der ganze Zeit hat. Ja, das war so krass. Oder seine Eltern, die ich einfach nicht kennen. Das ist auch so ein Ding. Das sind Eltern, die ich offensichtlich nicht kennen. Bei mir herrscht hier ganz oft dieses unterschwellige Bewusstsein, dass ich Bratkartoffeln lieben würde. Wahrscheinlich hast du als kleines Kind das mal irgendwie gemocht. Aber ich finde das immer so gut, diese Sachen, die man einmal erwähnt und dann, das ist jetzt, jetzt kommen ja gerade Weihnachten und man denkt so, hm, was mögen meine Brüder so und dann kommt so aus der Kindheit und Bruder hat mal in einem Nebensatz erwähnt, ja, ich finde Marzipan ganz gut und seitdem bekommt er zu jedem Geburtstag und jemals kiloweise Marzipan und er immer hilflos so, ja danke Leute, aber so kein Marzipan. Ich habe für zehn Jahre Jahre im HC-Bahn. Das ist so gut. Aber die Leute so beklammern sich. Deswegen erwähne ich immer, wo ich kann, dass ich Geld wahnsinnig ja, das ist eigentlich das eigentlich. Du magst auch Geld, ganz genau. Ja, genau, ich mag gern, ich bin Fan von Geld. Ich bin ein Riesen-Porsche-Fan, muss ich jetzt sagen, ganz offensichtlich. Geld, ab jetzt überall im Handel. Du kannst auch gerne mal Kritik geben und Feedback, was wir besser machen können und so. Also unser Podcast ist zwar schon sehr, sehr gut, aber halt mir auch nicht. Eigentlich finde ich Folgen mit Gästen nicht so gut. Ach, interessant. Welche Folgen fand ich schon da? Finde ich sehr gut. Aber das finde ich interessant, weil eigentlich war ja die Idee, dass das Podcast, wo sich so langsam zu einem Podcast entwickelt, wo wir wirklich auch sehr oft Gäste haben. Richtig? Aber ich glaube, ihr seid halt ernster und kontrollierter, wenn Leute da sind, was ja Sinn macht. Ja. Und lustiger wird es eigentlich, wenn ihr zu zweit seid, glaube ich. Also hast du uns eingeladen mit dem Bewusstsein, dass du für eine schlechte Folge verantwortlich sein gehst? Ja, das war mir egal. Da können mich jetzt alle für erinnern. Ich werde jetzt, ich habe jetzt wahrscheinlich eh, mich hassen jetzt wahrscheinlich eh alle. Es wurde ja schon, irgendwer hat ja schon gepostet unter den letzten Podcasts, von wegen ... Ja, aber das hilft nicht. Warum, ja. Das war meine Mutter. Die wollte nicht, dass ich fremden Menschen nach Hause fahre. Ich habe tatsächlich auch mir überlegt, dass es ja schon ganz schön heikel von euch ist, dass ihr hier einfach hinkommt. Ich konnte ja auch irgendein creepy Typ sein und so. Und genau das macht mir jetzt schon wieder Angst. Also ich ziehe jetzt meine Maske ab und dann... Nein, dass bei uns da keine Alarmglocken angegangen sind. Nein, aber das... Ich habe hier aber seit zwei Männer und ich bin eine Frau. Aber ich finde das auch nicht creepy, das finde ich so schade. Weißt du, früher hat man das halt einfach Abenteuerfreudigkeit oder von mir aus auch Romantik genannt, einfach mal irgendwie Sachen zu machen, wo man sagt, fuck it, ich mache das einfach mal. Und heute creepy, creepy, creepy. Hö, was, du gehst einfach zu dir hin, creepy, creepy, creepy. Nein, weißt du, so fangen coole Geschichten an. Du kannst eigentlich sagen, Moby Dick, ich will den grössten Wahl der Welt besiegen. Das ist aber schon ein bisschen creepy, oder? Okay, alles klar. Ja Ja okay, dann nicht, dh. Weisst du, oder hier, ich breche in diese Schlossarm und diese schlafende Prinzessin zu küssen, das ist aber schon ein bisschen arg creepy. Ja, du hast recht, dann bleibe ich einfach bei mir bei meinen Schafen und mache gar nichts. Nee, du musst das Ring nach Mordor, du musst das Ring nach Mordor bringen. Aber bei den Schafen bleiben wir es noch creepiger. Ja, das stimmt, creepy ist nur eine scheisse Entschuldigung von Leuten, die einfach keinen Spaß in ihrem Leben haben wollen, keine Risiken eingehen und irgendwie Angst vor Abenteuern haben. Und wo sage ich, nein, fuck euer fucking creepy, so erlebt man tolle Geschichten, so wie wir zum Beispiel hier sind. Wir hätten jetzt sagen können, irgendwie finde ich es total creepy, zu einem Fan zu gehen, zu einem Fan nach Hause zu gehen, das ist total creepy. Ich hatte halt Angst, dass ihr creepy findet, dass ich euch schreibe. Nein, warum denn? Warum soll das denn creepy sein, wenn einfach zwei Menschen sich treffen? Ich glaube, meine Angst ist ja gar nicht, dass ich selber was creepy finde, sondern dass andere denken, was ich mache, wäre nicht normal. Ich wäre irgendwie komisch. Aber warum denn? Ich verstehe das nicht. Weil die Grundlage nicht da ist. Doch, natürlich Grundlage ist, dass man sich cool findet, da kann man sich doch mal treffen. Ist okay. Ja, ich finde euch cool, aber was habt ihr denn davon, dass ihr jetzt hier seid? Ja, weil du offensichtlich die coolen Lüste der Folge. Jetzt hör mal auf zu reden, es geht nicht ab. Hör mal auf, mir auf, mich anzuspritzen! Das wird G-Sack. So, jetzt ruhig. Ja, aber das ist genau so, Frodo wäre auch nicht nach Morlock gegangen, wenn Leute gesagt hätten, mach das mal nicht, es könnte creepy werden. Wirklich, der Deck war eben lustig gewesen, aber da hast du reingeredet bei mir. Jede einzelne Rom-Com, wenn man die wirklich so erzählen würde, wenn ich jetzt... Was? Ich finde es sehr schön, dass ihr die Realität festmacht an Rom-Coms und Fantasy-Geschichten und so, dass ihr das so...
Rom-Coms? Romantic Comedy? Achso.
Ich würde sagen, du kannst jeden Plot von Romantic Comedy, wenn ich dir jetzt so erzählen würde, jemand würde sagen, das ist ein bisschen creepy, oder?
Aber das ist voll schade. Ja, natürlich.
Ich finde das total schade, ich glaube, das ist ein Problem.
Ja, aber du machst es doch selber. Du hast in unserem Chat achtmal das Wort creepy benutzt, obwohl es überhaupt nicht creepy ist.
Ja, weil ich euch nicht kenne und Angst hatte, ihr findet das total gruselig, dass ihr schreibt und habt ja auch eine Katzenallergie. Warum denn das ist so frisch, das ist so frisch normal. Aber dann komme ich mir wieder so komisch vor, weil ich habe in meinem Leben schon so oft geschrieben, nee, ich finde das überhaupt nicht creepy, ich finde das überhaupt nicht creepy und dadurch komme ich mir wie ein mega creep vor. Ja, aber das ist ja auch kein Geheimnis, dass du offensichtlich mega creep bist. Ja. Ja! Also das sind offensichtlich massive Probleme. Er hatte auch so ein Kind auf dem Strassenrand, wo wir einfach langgefahren sind, sehr laut Musik gemacht als angeflirteten Kind. Wo ich mir auch denke ... Als Gag, mein Gott! Nein, du hast dein ernstes Gesicht und dein Flirting-Face aufgesetzt. Das Gute ist, dass das Kind das ja nicht realisiert. Nee, das ist wie bei Katzen. Obwohl, das ist jetzt eigentlich kein gutes Argument, dass das Kind das nicht realisiert. Das Kind weiss nicht, dass es was Falsches. Ja, natürlich nicht. Neugierig. Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich finde es überhaupt nicht creepy, ich freue mich sehr, hier zu sein. Ich finde es alles toll, es ist auch nicht überhaupt nicht creepy, zu fragen, ob man eine Katzenallergie hat. Das ist einfach nur rücksichtsvoll und nett. Mir war es unangenehm zu sagen, dass ich eine Haarallergie habe.
Ich finde das lustig, weil das ist so ein bisschen unspezifisch. Also gegen alle Haare generell. Mir wurde mit dem Alter von acht Jahren gesagt, du hast eine Haarallergie. Du wirst sie in dieser Welt sehr schwer haben. Außer du lebst unter Fischen. Aber wie lebst du denn dann mit den Haaren, also mit deinen Barthaaren zum Beispiel? Das ist eine Perücke. Und die Barthaare? Die habe ich angeklebt. Die ist einzig. Woraus sind die denn? Nee, es gibt so eine Revelle-Klebe, diese Bausätze, ja, Klassiker, ein Jungs-Gag. Warum hast du denn dann keinen volleren Bart angeklebt? Ne, weil ich dachte, damit man das alles Kuderzucker, das meiste Kuderzucker. Damit man den abkauft, dass ich noch in der Stimmephase bin, dass ich so jung bin. Wie alt bist du? 21. Ich bin noch nicht 30. Und hast du einen Freund? Das fand ich ziemlich gut, dass das die erste Frage war. Ich habe dich gestalkt und ich sage dir jetzt einen Namen und ich möchte einfach, dass du sagst, welche Emotionen da bei dir hochkochen. Tamara Seybold. Gar keine Emotionen, wer ist das? Tamara Seybold ist die Gewinnerin des ARD-ZDF-Förderpreises Frauen und Medientechnologie. Da war das Stalken aber nicht sehr schwierig, das ist ja der erste Link oder der zweite. Es geht noch weiter, es geht noch weiter, denn du warst nominiert für den ARD-ZDF-Medientechnologie-plus-Frauen-Award und hast nicht gewonnen! Herzlichen Glückwunsch trotzdem! Happy Birthday! Im Gegenteil, du hast den letzten Platz gemacht. Ja, was war da los? Was war da los? Das, also, erst mal war das überhaupt nicht meine Idee, da mitzumachen. Ich hatte meine Diplomarbeit fertig. Die war dann so gut, dass dann so Leute auf mich zukommen sind, willst du da nicht teilnehmen? Nee, also die Leute von meinem Institut meinten halt, ich glaube einfach nur, um das Institut ein bisschen zu promoten und weil es halt cool ist, so bei der E-Technik Frauen am Institut zu haben und das irgendwie als Aushängeschild zu nutzen, haben die dann gemeint, schick da, mach da doch mal mit und schick da was ein. Ja. Und ja, hab ich dann halt gemacht. Du wurdest benutzt, weil du eine Frau bist. Wenn ich aber ... genau, genau, ganz genau. Wie fühlst du dich dabei? Das passiert oft bei uns an der Uni, glaube ich.
Auch wenn irgendwie mal so eine Fotoreihe gibt oder irgendwie Fernsehen an irgendein Institut kommt, um zu filmen, was die da machen, dann holen die zwei Frauen, die sonst irgendwie im Sekretariat sitzen, nach vorne und die müssen dann... Ziehen ihnen so einen Kittel an, einfach so eine Brille auf, hier, mach mal.
Ziehen ihnen den Kittel aus vor allem.
Ja, und deswegen sehen Wissenschaftler im Fernsehen immer so unbeholfen aus, weil sie irgendwann einfach so Säuren von einem Glas in den anderen schon wieder zurückschütten, weil es einfach die Sekretärin ist, die keine Ahnung von Wissenschaft hat wahrscheinlich. Damit impliziere ich jetzt, dass in der Wissenschaft keine Frauen arbeiten würden. Das war die Prämisse dieses Witzes, was nicht stimmt, was sexistisch ist. Du musst mir den Witze erklären, das ist echt uncool. Nein, du bist es, nein, ich erkläre nicht, dass diese Prämisse... Gut, unsere Hörerin erklärt uns, dass unsere Witze erklären uncool ist, wie gut es das denn. Nein, ich erkläre, dass meine Prämisse falsch war, und natürlich sind auch Frauen ganz tolle Wesen, die ganz klug sind und ganz richtig tolle Sachen machen können. Du redest davon so, als wäre das so ein Fabeltier, ganz tolle Wesen. Ja, ich glaube, wenn ich da gewonnen hätte, hätten die irgendwie einen Film gedreht bei uns am Institut. Ja, ich weiß, ich habe mir alle Filme angeguckt, und ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass du gewonnen hättest, nur wegen diesem Film. Ja, aber als ich die Filme gesehen habe, war ich ganz froh, dass ich nicht gewonnen habe. Ja, weil das ist wirklich das Unangenehme, weil man gewinnt einen Preis für einen Wissenschafts-Award und anstatt einfach den Gewinner darüber reden zu lassen, ja, habe ich hier diese Formel gelöst und E ist gleich MC, oh, Moment mal, Quadrat, ja, sowas in der Richtung habe ich immer und sowas, aber dann müssen die immer noch so, ja, dein Privatleben und oh, du spielst gerne den Fußball. Und dann laufen die durch eine Blumenwiese und erzählen, was ihre Hobbys sind und so, ja, ganz schlimm. Genau, dann treten wir doch mal den Fußball, was ist einfach immer mega awkward, dass man sich denkt, warum, niemand schaut es an und interessiert sich dafür, ich bin im Schachklub und ich habe mit 18, das interessiert keine Sau. Aber was hättest du gemacht, wenn man dich gefragt hätte, was kannst du, du wärst dann gejoggt einfach, du wärst dann gejoggt, lachend gejoggt. Das ist jetzt nicht nur mein Lebensinhalt. Genau. Ich meine, mit dem Podcast-Ufer. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich keinen beigegeben und gemacht, was die von mir wollten und mich total geärgert. Und es ist wahrscheinlich dieses Wasserleichen-Syndrom. Also ich etabliere ein neues Prinzip, das Wasserleichen-Prinzip, denn es ist nämlich so, dass wenn eine Wasserleiche in einem Film gezeigt wird, dann darf die nicht so aussehen wie eine echte Wasserleiche, weil echte Wasserleichen nicht echt aussehen. Echte Wasserleichen sehen aus wie eine Puppe. Das würde man nicht glauben, also wenn der Maskenbildner die wirklich so bauen, weil die sind dann total aufgebläht und weiß und sehen halt mega strange aus. Und wenn man das in einem Film zeigen würde, würde man dann sagen, das ist doch eine Puppe offensichtlich. Deswegen müssen die die extra unrealistisch machen, damit die echt wirken. Das finde ich sehr interessant. Das ist das Wasserleichensyndrom. Du arbeitest halt normal und dann sagst du, das sieht nicht echt aus. Nimm mal hier die Petrischale und guck mal durchs Mikroskop, das ist echter. So, dass sie versuchen, es möglichst echt zu machen, damit der Zuschauer denkt, das ist so, obwohl es eigentlich unecht ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich genau das Wasserleichensyndrom. Das ist spannend. Falls ihr eine vollständige Sammlung all meiner lustigen Syndrome und aller Fotos von Stefan haben möchtet, geht jetzt auf Kindle. Dann geht jetzt auf pufopedia.de, unserer neuen Enzyklopädie. Du lachst, ist aber wirklich kein Witz. Echt jetzt? Ja. Haben wir wirklich jetzt? Gut, dann weißt du denn nichts davon. Noch gibt es Serverprobleme, aber vielleicht... Das sind die Probleme. Ich hoffe, wenn diese Folge online geht, dann gibt es Pufopedia, die offiziell das Podcast-Ufo-Wikipedia-Seite, wo man alles Wissenswerte reinschreiben und lesen kann. Wir tun es nicht, irgendjemand macht es, also wenn ihr mal nachmittags Zeit habt, schreibt einfach mal voll alle coolen Sachen, transkribiert unsere Folgen, alles, weil wir sind, genau wenn so eine Situation aufkommt wie du, oh wann war das noch mal, wurde das noch mal gesagt, in welcher Folge, kannst du da reinschreiben hier, stalking, stalking, stalking und hast dann genau die Folgen. Pfopedia, das hätte ich mal gebraucht. Ein abschliessener Zyklopik.
Ein mega Eintrag würde ich wetten nach der Folge.
Ja.
Du hast, glaube ich, einen längeren Eintrag als wir, weil wenn man mehr über dich weiss.
Ja, mit genau dem Foto, das du gerade angesprochen hast, ist dann das.
Ja, wir können auch gleich ein Gruppenbild machen mit den Katzen.
Das finde ich aber ein bisschen creepy.
Ja, ist mir egal.
Ja, sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Ich möchte das ja nur unter mein Bett legen und neben mein Bett hängen. Unter dein Bett legen? Unter mein Bett legen. Okay, it's getting really creepy. Ich habe ein Wasserbett, das sieht dann so aus, als hätte ich euch ertränkt, so ein bisschen. Dann kommen wir jetzt nochmal zurück auf deine... Ja, ich hatte irgendwie zwei Sachen, die ich angefangen habe. Deine Teekisse mit dem Klimmchen. Ach ja, genau. Genau, die haben meine Eltern mir mitgebracht und jetzt könnt ihr ganz betroffen gucken, meine Eltern haben sich ja kurze Zeit später getrennt. Ja Mensch, Gott sei, endlich. Das tut mir sehr leid. Ich lache mal unangenehm jetzt. Das ist halt so die letzte Erinnerung, die ich habe, wo meine Eltern was gemeinsam gemacht haben und das, weiss nicht. Scheiße, Mann, echt? Ja, ich habe doch gesagt, ja, es ist okay. Von allen Bildern im Raum habe ich halt das, das in meinem Sichtfeld ist. Es ist okay, es ist okay. Ich finde das aber unabhängig davon auch schön, das Bild. Oder ist jetzt in der jedem Bild. Romantisch, Liebe, wie auch immer. Ja, Klimt der Kuss heißt das Bild, glaube ich. Ich ziehe jetzt nach Köln und wir haben gestern zusammen eine Matratze gekauft. Das zieht du zusammen? Was ein wichtiger Schritt ist in unserem Privatleben. Und wir waren zusammen im Matratzenlager und wir haben dann darüber diskutiert. Also wir haben zusammen eine Matratze einkam. Ich kam rein und dachte schon, wow, weil du brauchst etwas, er braucht eine Matratze und kommt in einen Laden, wo es nur Matratzen gibt. Das ist das Brüste. Manche brauche ich Küchentücher, dann werde ich gerne einen Laden, wo es nur Küchentücher gibt. Ich nicht? Da musst du dich entscheiden, das ist ja schrecklich. Du kannst dich entscheiden, du hast die komplette Macht. Aber das ist so ein bisschen das Subway-Phänomen, weil die ersten paar Male, die ich beim Subway war, bin ich zum Schalter hingegangen und habe gesagt, ja, ich hätte gerne ein Sandwich. Und dann kam immer so, ach wirklich, ist das so. Ja, aber was soll man denn sonst sagen? Genau das gleiche, und dann dachte ich auch, ich sage jetzt, wenn ich hingehe und sage, ich hätte gerne eine Matratze und sie guckt sich um so, no shit, wirklich. Aber man muss dir irgendwas sagen. Eben, das gleiche hatte ich letztens, nee, vor ein paar Jahren beim Weihnachtsbaum stand, wo es nur Weihnachtsbräume gibt und ich sollte einen Weihnachtsbaum holen. Ich hätte gerne ein Schlauchboot. Ja, nee, wir haben zusammen eine Matratze, wir haben Probeliegen und wir haben zusammen eine Matratze eingekauft und ich glaube, das war das schwulste, was ich in meinem Leben getan habe. Und ihr habt zusammen Probe gelegen? Ja. Welche Größe hatte die Matratze? Wir haben jetzt 140, ich sag schon, wir wir. Ja, es klingt die ganze Zeit so. Wir haben uns jetzt für eine 1,40er mal 1,2 Meter entschieden. Wir haben uns testweise die 1,40er, ich dachte, das wäre zu klein. H3, nee, H2. Ich dachte, wir brauchen die 1,80er. Im Endeffekt ist die H2 geworden, wir dachten erst H3, weil Florentin deutlich, deutlich über 80 Kilo wohnt. Je größer die Zahl, desto härter die Matratze? Genau, härter. Wir haben sehr lange dafür gebraucht, wofür dieses H steht. Und dann habe ich auch, was ich nicht geschafft habe, wir waren da ungefähr drei Stunden in diesem Laden, ja, da waren es auch fünf, und ich habe die ganze Zeit versucht, so, so, ich meine, Wissen, was ich mir da vorher angelesen habe, ich habe mir ein gewaltes Matratzenwissen angelesen, um die Verkäuferin zu beeindrucken, ja, und creepy. Das ist ein bisschen creepy. Und dann wollte ich ihr die ganze Zeit sagen, Menschen habe ich mich herausgefunden, schlafen 20 Jahre lang. Bo weiß jeder. 20 Jahre lang deines Lebens schläfst du. Das ist auch nicht mal wissend, das ist einfach offensichtlich. Ich habe es mir noch nie nachgerechnet. Genau, es hat nicht mal nachgerechnet. Man weiß es, aber es ist natürlich noch im Prinzip bezahlt. Wenn du acht Stunden pro Tag schläfst, ist es ein Drittel deines Tages und somit ein Drittel deines Lebens. Das ist nicht mal wissend. 20 Jahre, und deswegen habe ich die ganze Zeit gesagt, ich soll damit werben, zwanzig Jahre man auf diesem Ding verbringt, was man da verkauft, aber haben sie nicht akzeptiert. Die hatten da, dass du Geld dafür willst wahrscheinlich. Dann zitiere mal einen Gag von dir gestern, weil das fand ich ganz lustig. Es ist nett, dass du mal auch Gags, die du als seine verkaufst und mir wirklich gut markierst. Ja, ja. Da kam ich in Opa rein und worauf ich nicht gesagt habe, sie schlafen zwanzig Jahre ihres Lebens auf dieser Matratze, die sie jetzt kaufen, also entscheiden sie sie gut. Bein Opa rein und worauf ich nicht gesagt habe, sie schlafen 20 Jahre ihres Lebens auf dieser Matratze, die sie jetzt kaufen, also entscheiden sie sie gut, wo und ihn sagte, pass auf, ich schlafe nicht mehr 20 Jahre, was ich sehr lustig fand. Dankeschön dafür. Wir schlafen den Rest seines Lebens. Oh, doppel, doppel, wir sind zu weit weg von High Five. Wir waren uns gestern so nah. Ich habe mir einen einzigen Gag vorbereitet für den heutigen Tag und ich habe schon zweimal versucht, ihn unterzubringen und es hat nicht funktioniert. und ich denke mir, Und ich denke mir, soll ich das Thema nochmal aufmachen, mein einziges Gag war, ich lese dir vor. Machst du einfach völlig zusammenhanglos. Ja, Matratzenkauf. Das war das schwulste, was ich jemals gemacht habe und ich habe mal einem Mann eingeblasen. So, das war mein Gag, das war der einzige Gag, den ich mir vorbereitet habe. Und da ich ihn jetzt schon zweimal angesetzt habe, dachte ich mir, ich kann es noch ein drittes Mal machen. So, ich bin duid. Aber ich möchte jetzt fragen, welche Matratze es geworden ist. Ne, ob das stimmt. H2. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie viel Wahres an den Dingen dran ist, die ihr erzählt. Ach, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Zum Beispiel diese Masche, die ich unglaublich amüsant finde und auch die Anekdoten lustig finde, die wahrscheinlich wahr sind, aber ja auch alle in der Vergangenheit liegen, dass ihr beide so unerfahren seid bei Frauen und das alles irgendwie so ein Buch mit ... Das ist alles erfunden. Da ist alles erfunden, oder? Das ist alles erfunden. Da haben unsere Ghostwriter lange daran gearbeitet. Ich glaube, die ungarischen Kinder haben da sehr lange an der Perfektion gearbeitet. Aber ist das nicht eher was, was in der Vergangenheit liegt? Klar. Ich sag mal so, wir sind ja schon ... Also die Gags sind Arbeit, klassisch. Der ganze Podcast ist reine Arbeit. Ich sag mal so, wir versuchen schon so mindestens 80 bis 100 Gags pro Folge zu schreiben. Daran schreibt man normalerweise einen Monat. Wir jetzt als erfahrenen Gag-Schreiber schreiben da jetzt ungefähr, sagen wir mal eine Woche dran. Deswegen können wir jede Woche auch diese Anzahl an Gags gewährleisten. Aber habt ihr nicht auch noch einen Job? Wir haben einen Job nebenbei, also kein Privatleben, das ist nicht gelogen, wir haben kein Privatleben. Und daher kommt das, ja, wir müssen uns so viele Gags über Frauen ausdenken, dass wir keine Zeit haben, Erfahrung mit Frauen. Manchmal müssen wir Erfahrungen machen. Hey, Entschuldigung, Emil ist gerade drin. Wenn ihr euch gefragt habt, was eben massiv übersteuert hat in eurem Ohr. Ja, das tut mir leid. Das Printen, das Print war trotzdem eine gute Idee. Wo waren wir? Achso, du hast gerade erzählt, dass ihr keine Zeit habt für Frauen.
Ne, wir sind aber einfach auch so verkopft, ich glaube, wir können niemals eine normale Beziehung führen.
Man wäre einfach so awkward. Also wir waren selber so, wir sind so, wir sind so Kalikaturen von Menschen.
Weil es konstant auf einer Metaebene sind, wir haben einfach den Punkt des Erlebens übersprungen.
Das ist so, wie wenn ein alter Mann auf sein Leben zurückblickt und alles niederschreibt.
Wir haben diesen Punkt mit 17 erreicht, wo wir einfach nur noch zurückblicken und alles aus so einer schwebenden Distanz wahrnehmen und überhaupt nichts mehr erleben. Wir haben, glaube ich, zwei Jahre unseres Lebens gelebt, so von 14 bis 16, hatten da nichts mit Frauen zu tun, deswegen ist es einfach ein abgeschlossenes Thema. Und jetzt ist alles nur noch so betrachtet, so weises von oben herunter betrachtet. Aber irgendwann geht euch vielleicht ja Stoff aus und dann müsst ihr nochmal weiterleben. Genau, dann muss man ins Feld gehen, ziehen, ordentlich Leute durchnageln, um dann, sagen wir mal, darüber reden zu können. Ja, aber ist es nicht wirklich so, dass teilweise, wenn du in so einer Situation bist, denkst, okay, jetzt möglichst viel Comedy-Material abstauben, yeah, einfach weil jetzt ist die Gelegenheit da, jetzt könntest du einfach zehn Minuten Stand-Up einfach rausfahren. Den Zufall eines lustigen Momentes erzwingen. Ja, genau. Uns haben also ein paar Umfragen, die wir in Auftrag gegeben haben, haben auch ergeben, dass quasi alle Gags schon gemacht wurden mit Frauen. Mario Barth aus der, ich habe alles schon abgeräumt, Atze-Schröder-Ecke, die haben alles schon mitgenommen, was mit Frauen und aus einer erfolgreichen Mitfrauen-Ebene kommt. Aber jetzt kommen wir natürlich die Unerfahrenen, auch Luke Mockridge ist ja ein wahnsinniger Womanizer. Den kann ich übrigens also da bin bevor ich den podcast gehört habe und ihr habt euch dann immer über den lustig gemacht und so weiter dann war er bei euch in der folge da war ich dann überrascht weil ich fand der wirkte eigentlich ganz nett dann habe ich mir aber irgendwie ein youtube-video oder irgendwas von ihm angeguckt ich glaube ein auftritt bei stefan raab und ich konnte ich habe das nicht ertragen, um ehrlich zu sein. Ja, das haben wir ihm auch versucht zu sagen, dass er das mal wassen soll. Total unangenehm. Ja, aber er ist halt so ein erfolgreicher Typ und ist halt seine Persona und wir haben uns die Persona am Schreibtisch überlegt, unerfolgreich mit Frauen. Einfach weil wir glauben, dass das bei Leuten gut ankommt. Aber es ist tatsächlich immer wieder interessant zu sehen, wie anders uns die Leute wahrnehmen, als wir uns wirklich wahrnehmen. Das merkt man zum Beispiel, da kommen dann auch so Nachrichten so, hey, zu dir, zu Homestory von wegen, ja, das können wir auch mal bei mir machen, und dann komme ich einfach rum mit einem Kasten Bier und dann nehmen wir auf und man denkt so, warum, also das ist so ganz weit weg von unserer Lebensrealität, dass man so, komm, wir setzen uns mal mit einem Kasten Bier zusammen, das ist so, wir sind nicht in diesem studentischen, wir setzen uns abends mal zusammen und das ist so ein bisschen komisch, dass man immer das Gefühl hat, okay, unsere Hörer mögen uns ja zu einem gewissen Grad, finden uns sympathisch, verstehen uns aber trotzdem nicht, was ja eigentlich immer so die Grundintention ist, wenn man so was machen will, man denkt ja so, okay, wir haben irgendwas zu erzählen, wäre cool, wenn es da draußen Leute gibt, die ähnlich sind und die uns verstehen, weil letztendlich möchte man ja irgendwo verstanden werden und deswegen macht macht man sowas, aber dann zu sehen, dass dann tatsächlich doch nicht, und die Leute denken vielleicht auch, dass es halt vieles, was wir zählen, so irgendwie übertrieben ist oder gespielt oder irgendwie so eine Comedy-Persona ist und dass wir eigentlich ganz normale Typen sind, die aber ha ha ha, wie lustig wäre es, wenn wir keine Ahnung von Frauen hätten, aber dann denken, ja, ja, wir gehen da mal ein bisschen hier Bier trinken und dann reissen wir ein paar Frauen auf, und so, nee, wir meinen das durchaus ernst. Das finde ich aber total cool. Ich finde aber interessant, dass der Mythos besteht und würde es auch gerne nicht auflösen. Ich glaube, das war meine grösste Hoffnung, beziehungsweise meine grösste, wenn du verbrauchst. Dass ihr anders seid, dass ihr voll die, na egal, geilen Stecher seid. Nee, Quatsch, ich habe die ganze Zeit, ich glaube, das ist das, was ich an dem Podcast auch so mag, dass ihr das Gefühl habt, ihr zieht da nicht gross eine Show ab, was vielleicht, weshalb ich auch im Podcast inzwischen auch ein bisschen lieber höre als sanft und sorgfältig, weil ihr ein bisschen Jan ist ein wahnsinniger Womanizer, muss man sagen. Offener seid oder ein bisschen Authentischer meinst du? Ein bisschen weniger darauf bedacht, möglichst nichts. Also bei saft und Sorgfältig ist es halt immer, ich meine, ihr kennt den Jan jetzt nicht, den Jan, wie das jetzt klingt. Ich habe das Gefühl, du nährst dich einem Satz, wo ich dir zur Not mit Wasser in die Sicht würde. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich, ich kann so nicht arbeiten, wenn du eine Pistole auf mich hältst. Aber du sagst, wo wir nicht versuchen, möglichst cool dazustehen. Es ist ja auch schon eine gewisse Coolness. Es wirkt authentischer. Ja, aber es ist ja, also viele Leute kokettieren ja auch mit diesem Image des, ich bin so ein Loser, ich bin so ein Nerd, weil das halt auch natürlich gerade zeitgeistmässig ist und auch gerade cool ist und auch viele Frauen auch so diese Linie fahren von wegen, keine Ahnung, ich will keinen Mann, ich will nur eine Flasche Bier oder sowas, so Tweets, dieser Zeitgeist-Zynismus zu sagen, so von von wegen, ich gehe nicht in den Club, ich bestelle mir eine Pizza nach Hause, so. Auch Nein-Gags zu sagen, diese ganzen Gags, alle wollen eine Freundin, dann diese andere Pinguin, wo ich ein Jahr verbrauche, um zu verstehen, was das gemeint ist, dann die Pinguin gehen in die andere Richtung, ich will lieber auf Netflix gucken. Ja genau, genau das ist das. Das ist fast schon cooler, ein Nerd zu sein, als ein cooler Stecher, der rausgeht in die Bars und Frauen aufreist. Deswegen kann man natürlich auch sagen, man versucht dadurch cooler zu sein und sympathischer zu wirken, indem man sich das baut. Es gibt auch so Steven Merchant oder so, da viele Stand-up-Comedians mal so diesen Loser-Charakter und es ist so furchtbar und ich bin so introvertiert und bla bla bla bla bla und diesen Zeitgast- Zynismus abzugreifen, den viele ja auch nur vorschieben, wo es dann tatsächlich gar nicht so ist, wo dann Leute, von denen du weisst, das ist überhaupt nicht so. Das ist genauso mit diesem schüchternen Punkt, ich will dir das nicht vorwerfen, aber es ist halt in gewisser Weise cool, schüchtern zu sein, weil es halt so dieses, ich lebe in meiner eigenen Welt mit Katzen und ich schaue nur Netflix, was alle machen, aber es ist so ein bisschen diese neue Coolness zu sagen, ich bin schüchterner Nerd und ich lebe nur in meiner eigenen Welt und bla bla bla bla so, ohne dir das jetzt vorzuwerfen, aber das dreht sich dann und da ist halt immer das Problem, die Leute, die wirklich so sind und wirklich Nerds sind und wirklich nicht mit Leuten reden können, die fallen dann halt so ein bisschen raus, weil die haben dann nichts mehr, womit sie sich identifizieren können. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Lady. Das ist eben hier. Ja, das stimmt. Ich will damit nur sagen, nur weil wir sagen, wir sind uncool, heißt es nicht, dass wir deswegen ehrlich sind. Also wir sind zwar ehrlich, aber man kann nicht immer sofort diese Argumentation schließen. Eben, deshalb interessiert mich das ja, weil ich glaube schon, dass die Geschichten, die du zum Beispiel erzählst, stimmen. Also irgendwelche Anekdoten, wo du dann zum Beispiel dieses Mädel, was im Supermarkt an der Kasse gearbeitet hat und so. Oh ja. Ich glaube das schon. Ah, Magdalena. Das ist natürlich jetzt peinlich, wenn das nicht stimmt. Clara. Ja, ich habe tatsächlich noch ihre E-Mail-Adresse. Ich könnte ihr jetzt noch schreiben und können sagen, hier, guck mal, was du verpasst hast. Ich bin jetzt im Fernsehen. Ich habe jetzt hier ein 3000-Klick-Video auf Vimeo. Hier seht ihr ein Video, wo ich wahnsinnig fett bin und mich ausziehe und einen Mardersong singe. Aber schau dir keine Videos von vor 2015 an. Aber da war ich auch schon cool. Steht auf. Ciao, mach's gut. Dankeschön, dass wir hier sein durften, dankeschön, dass du uns eingeladen hast, dankeschön, dass du die Fahrtkosten übernimmst. Ja, schade, dass nur 30 Minuten lang gedauert hat, der Podcast, aber vielen Dank dafür, vielen Dank für die Einladung, dass wir deine Katzen mal kennenlernen dürfen. Vielen Dank an deine Katzen auch, vielen Dank. Ich danke euch, das war sehr, sehr cool und mutig, dass ihr hierherkommen seid. Falls ihr mal uns einladen möchtet zu Aus nach Hause. Ja, das machen wir nicht nochmal. Ne, wir machen immer ab. Also nachdem er lebt, ich würde euch davon abraten. Und das Podcast-Ufo hebt für alle nur für alle nur ab. Muss ich jetzt noch den Jingle machen? Willst du ihn noch verabschieden? Den Jingle gibt es auch schon bei Rapide Rapante übrigens. Was gab es schon? Den ... Ja klar, natürlich. Echt? Ja, ja. Der ist ja von Ricky Gervais geklaut. Das habt ihr gelesen, weil ich. Ja, ja. Das ist wirklich gelesen. Ja, gut. Mein ganzes Lügengebäude. Und eigentlich wollte ich auch noch You Guys sagen. Aber es gab keine Gelegenheit dafür. Die ganzen coolen Sachen kommen jetzt alle an. Das wäre aber echt gut gewesen. Ah nein. Wir kommen einfach noch mal vorbei. Wir kommen jetzt jede Woche. Ja, wir machen jetzt jede Woche Homestory. In Aachen. Geil. Okay, dann macht's gut.
Denkt euch jetzt einen audiovisuellen
awkward Umarmung. Zehn Sekunden lang.
Und das Motto ist,
er hebt ab. Sous-titrage Société Radio-Canada